Hollywood history is littered with rags-to-riches
stories, though few of them are quite as literal
as Chris Pratt's.
Now the face of Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy movies, Pratt has come an incredibly
long way since he dropped out of college at
17 after just a single semester, taking the
road less traveled on his way to Tinseltown.
"I have a plan."
"You've got a plan?!"
"Yes."
After cutting his teeth playing sidekicks
and funny men, the character actor was immediately
promoted to the A-list when he won the role
of Marvel Studio's Peter Quill, aka Star-Lord.
Turn back the clock a few years, however,
and there were definitely no red carpets or
caviar.
So how did it happen?
Let's find out how Chris Pratt went from homeless
beach bum to Hollywood hotshot.
After dropping out of school, Pratt had to
find ways to make ends meet, and he turned
out to be a natural at door-to-door sales.
He worked as a coupon salesman for two years,
learning skills that he claimed served him
well when he finally made his dream move into
acting.
His next gig was less white-collar — or
actually, more no-collar.
In need of a bit of extra cash, Pratt decided
to turn himself into what he described as
"a very, very low-rent Magic Mike."
"I would, just like slowly, awkwardly dance
and then take -- go down to my shorts and
they'd be like, 'Ohhh…'"
With next to nothing to lose and his twenties
looming, Pratt accepted an invitation from
an old friend who claimed to be living the
dream in Hawaii, and wanted his buddy to join
him.
The two young men lived out of a van, which
Pratt admits had its ups and downs.
On one hand, he was very free.
But on the other, he had no bathroom and the
van had a bit of problem with fleas and rats…
And of course, there was also the danger of
him turning into this:
"I am 35 years old, I am divorced, and I live
in a van down by the river!"
One of the part-time positions Pratt picked
up in the Islands of Aloha was waiting tables
at a Bubba Gump seafood restaurant.
It was while on shift at the diner that Pratt
had a chance encounter with Commando actress
— and shrimp fan — Rae Dawn Chong, who
was looking for actors for her comedy horror
short Cursed Part 3.
After being impressed by his enthusiasm, Chong
flew Pratt to L.A. to give him a shot — and
ended up providing him with the platform he'd
been waiting for.
Pratt’s next acting gig came when he landed
the role of Keenan in The Extreme Team, a
2003 Gen-X spy flick about a secret group
of Black Ops snowboarders.
That movie sounds ridiculous, but in the grand
scheme it was just another rung in the ladder
that Pratt had to climb on his way to becoming
Star-Lord.
Despite finally seeing himself as a professional
actor, things didn't exactly fall into place
right away in terms of auditions.
Pratt made some cash doing commercials, but
eventually his persistence paid off, landing
him the part of high school jerk Bright Abbott
on the WB drama Everwood.
Apparently, Pratt didn’t even really prepare
for this audition and landed the part by just
naturally being the type of character that
the directors were looking for — funny how
things work out.
Pratt wasted no time getting comfortable on
the set of Everwood where he would end up
portraying Bright in 89 episodes between 2002
and 2006.
When Everwood wrapped in '06, Pratt secured
a recurring role on long-running Fox favorite
The O.C., appearing in nine episodes as left-wing
activist — and occasional naked guitarist
— Che Cook.
After these roles, Pratt finally landed what
most people consider his "big-break" with
the role of Andy Dwyer on Parks and Recreation.
"My full name is Andrew, I think.
So… no?
Wait!
Yes."
"Let’s move on."
The critically acclaimed mockumentary opened
new avenues for Pratt, who attributes the
show's continued success to lead actress Amy
Poehler.
Amazingly, Pratt’s character, Andy Dwyer,
was only supposed to appear in five or six
episodes.
But when he turned out to be a fan-favorite,
he became part of the main cast for the show’s
entire run.
"Leslie, I typed your symptoms into the thing
up here and it says that you could have 'network
connectivity problems.'"
The success of Parks and Recreation and the
cult following that started to build around
Pratt's character made movie studios pay attention.
In the next few years, he had roles in 2011
Best Picture nominee Moneyball, Judd Apatow's
2012 comedy The Five Year Engagement, the
war drama Zero Dark Thirty and 2013’s Best
Picture nominated film, Her.
With all of these strong big-screen performances
stacking up, it seemed like Pratt was poised
to shake the "funny friend" stereotype and
trade it up for something much bigger...
That much bigger thing would of course be
2014’s massive hit Guardians of the Galaxy.
Director James Gunn admitted that when Pratt's
name first appeared on his desk, he scoffed
at the idea of him leading the line as Star-Lord.
Gunn even said that there was no way that,
quote, "The chubby guy from Parks and Rec"
was going to star in his movie.
At this point, Pratt had already been turned
down for the parts of James Kirk in the Star
Trek reboot and Jake Sully in Avatar because
he didn't have the "it factor," and he himself
was worried that he was "too fat to play a
superhero."
But in the end both he and Gunn were wrong.
As soon as the director saw Pratt reading
for the part, he was sold — and apparently
knew he had found his Star-Lord just 20 seconds
into the audition.
Just like that, the part was his, though that's
pretty much all Pratt knew for a good while.
The actor has explained that his contact with
Marvel Studios was brief at that stage, to
the point where he wasn't even allowed to
see the screenplay.
The radio silence lasted so long that Pratt
still had no clue what was happening when
he met up with Gunn to discuss the movie.
Thankfully, that meeting went very well, and
was enough to calm Pratt's nerves.
After that the actor was ready to become:
"Star-Lord."
"Who?"
"I'm Star-Lord, man.
Legendary outlaw?"
At that point, there was only one thing left
to do.
Pratt tipped the scale at 300 pounds when
he went in to audition for Guardians of the
Galaxy, and it was only after winning the
role that he made a vow to shed some of it
— sixty pounds, to be exact.
The actor lost the weight over a period of
six months using a workout that included running,
swimming, kickboxing and even a full triathlon.
For some reason, however, dancing wasn't part
of his fitness regimen:
"Dance off, bro!
Me vs. you!"
"It's on!"
By the time the Guardians of the Galaxy shoot
began, Pratt looked like genuine superhero
— with the six pack and all.
This ripped bod, coupled with his undeniably
lovable personality, has helped Pratt’s
career take off, scoring him leading roles
in big movies like Jurassic World, Passengers
and The Magnificent Seven.
As Pratt's movie career continues to heat
up, one thing is becoming more and more clear.
The guy is a seriously ripped, seriously funny
actor who isn’t going anywhere — except
right to the top of Hollywood’s A-list.
Of course, no matter how famous he gets, Pratt
will always be this guy:
"Yup, yup.
S--t my pants on camera.
Check!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!